so we have updated uh we have these
updated vaccines both the this year's
influenza vaccine and the the newest
updated coid vaccine in the province it
started to arrive in in September and
October and we continue to encourage
everybody in British Columbia who's
eligible to get those vaccines and to
get them at the same time and as you
know we started the process with people
in priority population so seniors
particularly our seniors and Elders over
the age of 6 five residents of Long-Term
Care Homes which have all been uh have
had opportunities to be vaccinated
across the province indigenous peoples
pregnant people healthcare workers of
course and people with those underlying
illnesses that make them at higher risk
of having more severe illness both with
influenza and also with
coid um most people by now have received
their invitations through our get
vaccinated system and I know uh lots of
people have been taking advantage of uh
the availability of vaccines across the
province uh to date we've administered
over a million doses of influenza
vaccine and I think the the total today
was 1 milon and uh 70,000 a little over
that and over 847 th000 doses of the the
coid
vaccines so I want to give a little bit
of an update on what we're seeing in
terms of uh the the key viruses that
cause illness this time of year and all
of these data are put up weekly now on
the
bccc's um respiratory illness page on
the dashboard there um so all of the
pieces that are in there give us a good
sense of what's Happening across the
province with all of the viruses that
we're concerned about so one of the big
things is we had a a fairly early peak
of coid um and it it has leveled off now
and started to come down so we're seeing
both things like the test positivity um
people who are SI sick with Co so cases
Hospital admissions have decreased in
this past 2 weeks um from a peak in
early October and critical care
admissions so people who are need ICU
care and deaths um from coid remain
relatively stable and again we know that
the people who are most at risk are
older people so our hospitalizations are
primarily in people who are over AG 60
and particularly um most of the severe
illnesses in older people over the age
of though I have to say unvaccinated
people at any age remain at greatest
risk and highest risk of having more
severe illness ending up in hospital and
we know as well um the potential of
having long coid after infection and I
just want to touch on a recent paper um
there were some media about this in the
last uh couple of weeks that really
shows us how effective vaccines have
been so this was the Sero prevalence
study that looked at how many people
have evidence of antibodies from
vaccination and or from infection across
the province by age group and what we've
seen is that older people were well
protected by vaccines which is great it
also means how important it is for us to
keep the updated vaccines to make sure
that we give a boost to that
protection and for most people in the
province we have this combin of
vaccination and infection that gives us
a high level of population immunity
around the province and for most of us
that meant that we were vaccinated the
infections that we had were very mild
and many people didn't even realize they
had that so that's that hybrid immunity
that we have so this emphasizes to us
the importance of getting these updated
vaccines that not only give a boost to
that protection against hospitalization
and more severe illness but but also um
protection against the strains that
we're seeing circulating right now and
from what we're seeing and that's again
on the the vccdc website you can see
that we're still seeing um Omicron
variations that are causing most illness
right now slight variations of the xbb
particularly so we're seeing a new one
called hb. one but also xbb 1.16 1.9 and
eg5 which has been around for the last
few months
the other viruses that we're looking at
of course are influenza and RSV and so
RSV test positivity has started to
increase in children so we're seeing
that primarily reflected in data from
Labs at uh BC Children's Hospital and
and other labs around the province and
what we're seeing now at is that we're
seeing levels that are kind of a little
bit above what we would expected this
time of year from prepandemic levels but
not what we saw last last year where we
saw a dramatic increase early on in the
season so overall RSV activity across
all ages Still Remains low but it's
starting to increase
now INF influenza as well we're starting
to see that increase and it's a bit more
normal from uh more in line with what we
used to see in the pre-pandemic days
it's mostly influenza A and the H1N1
strain of influenza A about 80% of the
influenza detection or that we've seen
very little influenza be
um right now and
interestingly uh there's one of the
strains of influenza be called Yamagata
that we haven't seen worldwide um in the
last 2 years so that's an interesting
phenomenon that we're watching as
well and while we won't have vaccine
Effectiveness data yet until a little
bit later in the season what we are
seeing is those strains that we're able
to do detective influenza show a really
good correlation with the ones the
clades we call them that are in the
vaccine so so far it's looking like a
good match which is another reason why
it's important to take that opportunity
now to get the vaccine as we're starting
to enter into more of the respiratory uh
illnesses particularly
influenza the other thing that we can
see on the bccdc dashboard is um we
monitor visits to uh community
Healthcare practitioners so primary care
physicians nurse practitioners for
people who go to seek medical attention
for Respiratory illnesses and that's
been gradually increasing since mid
August so this includes all of the
things that can cause influenza likee
illness including coid or SARS K2
influenza RSV but also what we're seeing
quite a bit of are still the ento and
adov viruses and these are the what we
generally say our common cold viruses so
we're seeing those still especially in
children we're also seeing that
pediatric emergency department visits
are gradually increasing but are below
historic levels and what we've seen is
they're not uh last year we saw that
rapid increase in both RSV and influenza
quite early in the season and we came a
very high peak in November we're we're
seeing a more normal pattern or a
similar pattern what we'd see before the
pandemic right
now so this uh changes that we're seeing
in coid or in the SARS K2 virus activity
levels remind us that there's still a
lot we have to learn um and that's one
of the things that we're paying
attention to as we go through this
season we're still coming out of the
pandemic and trying to understand the
patterns that we're going to see in the
future but also reminds us again the
importance of maintaining our immunity
particularly getting that boost from the
updated
[Music]
vaccines um um so data shows that as I
mentioned that coid is leveling off um
in our hospitals as well At Last count
there were 244 people in in BC in
hospital with a positive Co test and we
know that about 40% of them are there
because of coid and the majority who
have an incidental finding fory of
reasons and we only we were down to
eight people in critical care last
check um one of the other novel things
we've been doing since the pandemic
started was our Wastewater surveillance
and so I encourage people to look at
that again it's one of the things that
gives us a picture of what's happening
around communities and what we're seeing
is that the SARS K2 levels that we're
detecting in the Lower Mainland
Wastewater plants in particular um still
are increasing but it's leveled off and
in around the province we have uh plants
in uh the Island Health in interior in
the north now uh the SARS K2 loads are
either stabilizing or coming down so
that's important to watch and new this
year we also H have been uh checking the
Wastewater for RSV and influenza A and
influenza B and those are all up on the
website as well we're starting to see an
increase um particularly in influenza A
and in RSV and the Lower Mainland sites
in particular so that's a Harbinger that
we may be seeing more illness in the
community um in the next few weeks
so this is kind of more like what we
expected and it reminds us that this is
the time where it's important to get um
to get our protection as we're going
into the worst part of the season in the
next few
weeks November is also um no surprise to
people I'm sure we're seeing more people
with respiratory symptoms like cough and
sore throat and fever and um we one of
the things that we're reminding people
is that we we all know these healthy
habits that get us through these types
of Seasons these are important messages
and ones you'll start to hear more often
not just me saying it all the time but
on uh radio and TV reminds us of the
importance of doing those things that
we're all used to now that includes
staying home or staying away from others
if you have respiratory symptoms
especially a fever fever's generally a
sign that you have something that may be
infectious to others so fever and a
cough or fever and rash or fever um and
other illnesses that can be transmitted
to others like vomiting and
diarrhea so covering your cough wearing
a mask if you're recovering and around
others or if you're somebody at higher
risk consider wearing a well-fitted or
an n95 mask especially if you're in a
crowded indoor space with poor
ventilation with groups of people that
you don't know it's always important to
continue cleaning your hands regularly
with soap and water are using
alcohol-based hand rubs and of course
getting your updated vaccines that give
you that best protection so as I
mentioned most people now will have
received their notifications through the
get vaccinated system and it's not too
late in any way um now is the time to
get them we know that there's
availability across the province and uh
as I mentioned over a million doses of
uh of influenza vaccine and over 847
th000 doses so far far and 2third of
people have been getting them at the
same time so that's something that's
available this year that's makes it
easier for people as well um if you uh
most people are able to do this online
but I know there's challenges in
particular if you want to book yourself
as a family so I encourage you to call
the the number 833 838 2323 if you have
any issues and assistance and I want to
reassure people that we do have an
adequate supply of vaccines for
everybody to get them over the next few
weeks I did want to mention today uh a
little bit about the high path Aven
influenza outbreaks we're starting to
see again um in BC we know that at least
16 firms have been affected mostly in
the Fraser Valley but also some on
Vancouver Island and this is related to
the migratory patterns of wild fowls so
ducks and geese as they do their global
migration and and they've just started
in the fall migration so the last uh we
had a lot of outbreaks in the spring of
this year and this was a phenomenon that
we've seen globally um but particularly
across North America and in Europe um
and we weren't sure whether we would be
seeing it come back again in the fall
with the fall migration um but we have
started just in the past couple of weeks
again and I know this is a major issue
for the poultry farmers and a lot of the
biocurity measures that they put in
place place to try and protect their
flocks The Strain we're seeing is one
called influenza it's an Aven influenza
so that means it's in Birds primarily
it's called
h5n1 and so far globally there's been
very little spill over infecting humans
but it can happen and it it's very
concerning this time of the year when
we're starting to see human influenza
viruses circulate as well so we really
urge people who work on or live on
poultry Farms working with Birds um to
prioritize getting their influenza
vaccine it's an important way of
protecting yourself from influenza and
making sure that you're not a potential
source of infection to the flocks as
well we're working very carefully are
very closely with the Canadian food
inspection agency with our Animal Health
Partners here in BC and uh our Public
Health veterinarians at the bccdc to uh
ensure that the bird health is monitored
in the flocks um we also have seen some
wildbird deaths related to influenza to
this Aven influenza many of the wild
poultry so ducks and geese don't get
very sick with it but some of them can
so if you do come across uh a dead bird
you can report it by calling 1866 431
bird so that's
2473 and uh they uh May test it for
highpath Avan influenza but I do want to
say only handle it if you need to
wearing gloves and make sure you wash
your hands well
afterwards so just you know the risk of
infection is low for most of us um given
the limited contact we generally have
with infected Birds um but people like
workers on poultry Farms Farm families
and others who have close contact with
birds are really um encourage you and to
make sure you're taking the appropriate
precautions and to get vaccinated
so in summary we are seeing a a mixed
pattern a pattern that's more like what
we used to see prior to coid being one
of the um one of the additional diseases
we had to deal with at this time of year
now is the time if you've not already to
get your updated coid 19 vaccine and
this year's influenza
vaccine and as we head into these winter
months we we uh expect a more usual
pattern with more influenza more SV and
we'll be watching to see what happens
with SARS kov V2 often what we see with
influenza is a second Peak after
Christmas and often with influenza B so
we'll be watching for that and it'll be
interesting to see what happens with the
SARS kov V2 virus as we go into the
winter so the most important things we
can all do are ones that we know staying
up to date on our vaccinations taking
regular precautions like covering your
mouth when you with your sleever your
elbow when you cough cleaning your hands
regularly and importantly checking in
with yourself and your children and
making sure if you are sick with
something that can pass on to others
that you stay away from people
especially people who are most at risk
so um postponing that visit to visit an
elderly relative if you're not feeling
well or people are are sick if you can
do
that these are things that we should all
be familiar with now these healthy
habits and they will what will get us
through these next few months and
continue to use to get us safely through
um and allow us to gather together as we
go into the holiday season so I'm going
to leave it with that and I'll turn it
over to minister Dix thank
you uh thank you very much Dr Henry uh
this is the fourth uh respiratory
illness season since the the pandemic
the co 19 pandemic began I think we've
all now had this experience together
whether we're healthcare workers are
involved in the Health Care system or uh
people involved in the community we know
that the actions that we take can make
our community more resilient can um
provide uh support and protection for
those we care for and those that we
don't know uh we know that each of us
has a role to play in that and I I think
it's important to reflect on that as the
weather gets colder of course our events
go inside this is the season when people
come together most for Holiday related
events uh and this is therefore a very
important time and a very important
opportunity if you have not yet been
vaccinated to get vaccinated and to do
all the other steps that Dr Henry and no
doubt I'll mention again we can take um
uh to reduce the spread spread of both
coid 19 influenza RSV and respiratory
illness in general and so I I want to
say a few things about where we stand
right now with respect to uh
vaccines um uh we are leaving Canada in
terms of vaccination right now this is
because of the takeup and the remarkable
efforts of uh pharmacies and healthcare
workers and health authorities around BC
mostly is people stepping up and getting
vaccinated as Dr Henry has said 1,
72,000 uh people have received uh their
flu vaccine in the first month of our
campaign
84745886780 um uh between 6 months and
11 had their appointments that's more
than 30,000 yesterday so the campaign
continues uh to be strong across BC
everyone knows that we started our
vaccination campaign much earlier than
other jurisdictions in the country nine
days earlier than the largest other
jurisdictions in the country and we were
benefiting from that uh um last year we
set a record for example an all-time
record for influenza vaccination in BC
at 1 million uh
775,000 and so the first month of our
campaign to be um at a, 72,000 shows
that we're in good shape but there is
opportunity across the province uh to
get vaccinated we've add we add
regularly add new appointments so if in
your area there seems to be a limited
amount of appointments on a given
attempt to get vaccinated there's some
communities that have less than 10%
availability over the next week
communities such as Oliver and a soy for
example we're going to be working to add
appointments in those areas and we
encourage people to keep checking back
in their system more than
1350 pharmacies are offering influenza
vaccination appointments over 1,200
pharmacies are offering Co 19
vaccination appointments about
1,160 exactly actually pharmacies are
offering both vaccines the majority of
people are getting the vaccines together
and I think um that is of course a good
idea and recommended we able as Dr Henry
has said we have ample Supply to meet
demand we've ordered um uh 2.8
million
to respond to their text message uh
click on book their appointment and get
both the co 19 uh vaccine and the
influenza vaccine I want to talk a
little bit bit about uh
hospitalization uh when we um uh briefed
you in advance of respiratory illness
season and told you about the planning
we were doing we talked about preparing
as we have every single year we did in
2020 and 21 and 22 and now in 23 in
advance of respiratory illness season
because we know that demand for Health
Care is increasing and we know that it
has been increasing as well year unto
year in our Province we have a dramatic
because of the strength of the Beast
economy we have many people coming to
British Columbia in large numbers every
year and in addition to that we have an
aging population increasing demand for
health care services and some of the
consequences of the pandemic have led to
an increase in that demand just to just
to give you know exactly what that is
last year we had very high levels of
hospitalization this year they are
higher so from October 8th even in a in
a respiratory illness season that as Dr
Henry has said has been relatively
stable from October 8th to November 7th
we have been caring for 337 more
patients per day than we did for the
same period last year that's inpatients
in hospital um as of last night that
number was
10,67 put in context it's reached a
height of um of uh
10, uh
170 over the last week it does go up and
down in the course of week so this week
it's gone from 9700 to where we are
about
10,070 that's
10,072 to be exact so um what that tells
you is there's a lot of people in the
hospital and that's why we've taken the
steps to to respond to that our healthc
care system is resilient and is being
and is responsive to this health
authorities have confirmed that they are
prepared for increased demand due to
respiratory illness season and you'll
recall last year demand went up in our
hospitals the peak of demand was 10,260
on onor around January 6th La last year
so we are still going to see a rising
level of demand for impatient Acute Care
in our hospitals but but they are
grateful and we are grateful for the the
determination of British Colombians to
get vaccinated in this period and we
have to continue to do that today as Dr
Henry has said there are 244 patients in
hospital eight and critical care who are
positive for Co 19 and that's lower than
last year but respirat illness season is
just starting and that's why we've taken
action to in improve access and flow
teams in place for all of our large
hospitals 7 days a week focused teams of
healthcare leadership administrators and
Physicians have been established on
critical care and emergency department
to support these Priority Services now
and in the future health authorities our
BC emergency health services and the
ministry continue to coordinate our
provincial capacity we are as one health
system with all health authority
partners coming together to ensure
people care the care they need and we
have formalized a standard provincial
seasonal surge response plan taking the
best of our response to co 19 and the
learnings from it in terms of beds we
have worked extensively with health
authorities over the summer to review
bed counts and the types of beds in
September I said as we prepared for the
season that our base our bed base has
been lifted to
9,880 happy to share that due to
additional work we are actually
resetting our net bed base base in
hospitals at
9,939 in addition to that we have some
1500 surge beds available as well for
the height of the season over the next
number of months to achieve this health
authorities have identified wish beds
could be regularized are Clinic
clinically equipped and are use
appropriate the benefit of
regularization means staff are no longer
in temporary lines that regular
positions are created that appropriate
support services are hired and that
overtime can potentially be reduced all
of which will lead to more patients
getting safer care with the right level
of wraparound Services we are also
adding more hospital at home beds across
the province a very successful program
we launched during the co 19 pandemic
which will con connect patients with
Safe Care in the comfort of their homes
as well we're working on initiatives to
ensure patients who no longer require
acute care can receive alternate level
of care in settings that include
long-term traditional or Community Care
all these measures will receive relieve
some of the pressure on hospitals and
help author Health authorities improve
patient flow in our hospitals and ensure
there is capacity in our system for our
winter surge season as noted in addition
to the 9,939 base beds we have we can
add 1500 surge beds if needed uh that
can be activated through the winter and
fall progress and obviously the progress
we're making through our health human
resources plan which we've talked about
a number of times before for the 70
actions focused on retraining
redesigning recruiting and training um
and and making adjustments to our
healthare system uh is having I think
very positive effects throughout the
system witness the enormous uh
participation of doctors in our new um
uh payment system which is improving
care for patients and communities this
is always been about putting Patients
First and people first and we all have a
role to play and I strong ly encourage
people to follow the consistent advice
about washing hands about coughing into
our sleeves about staying home when
we're sick and surely surely and
importantly taking the opportunity to
get vaccinated to follow the path of
British Columbia which is leading our
country in vaccinations and and improve
that it will help us in our health care
System but mostly it will help you as a
person stay well your family stay well
your loved ones stay well your your
grandparents stay well everyone you know
stay well it's those healthy habits that
all of us can follow and all of us have
learned during the pandemic that will
assist us this season as well thank you
very much and uh and uh ask Dr Henry to
return uh to the podium and we'll be
happy to take your
questions thank you Minister Dixon Dr
Henry as a reminder to media on the line
please press star one to enter the queue
you'll be able to ask one question and
one followup I'll start in the room
first any questions from the room go
ahead if you can identify yourself and
your outlet please go ahead hi this Jim
from CTV News Dr Henry I just want to
know how are the care home I'm sure if
Mr dicks can answer this but how are the
Care Homes doing right now are they
fully vaccinated uh we're hearing news
that um actually one of the care home
Vancouver has been hit really hard and
there's almost five deaths in there so
how are are the seniors doing our
parents and our grandparents are doing
very good question and yes uh a vaccine
has been offered in All Care Homes
across the province that's one of the
priorities that we started with um not
everybody received the vaccines or chose
to receive the vaccines but a vast
majority of people did um and we are
seeing some outbreaks of uh influenza as
well as uh um Co outbreaks in a few Care
Homes I'm not aware of the one you're
speaking about and what is causing it
but uh we do see that um all of these
viruses can spread quite quite rapidly
in Care Homes so uh it is something that
we're working very carefully closely
with our Care Home colleagues on and
health authorities across the province
are paying attention to this so we do
have uh on the bccdc dashboard the
reports of the outbreaks by the virus
once it's detected uh in each Care
Home great next question please hi Kate
Walker City News um the first question
it may be for Minister dicks um you
mentioned there's enough supply of
vaccines but some people are mentioning
There's issues booking um to get their
vaccine one senior shared their story
about trying to book a vaccine a couple
weeks Ag and it wasn't until well into
the new year that they were able to get
an appointment so I'm just curious if
there is kind of a surge in trying to
book appointments and having
difficulties there yeah and always with
the the system early on um there's some
uh there's been some glitches where a
lot of people have been trying to book
at once and we have heard um UNS
sporadic cases and I'll let the minister
talked to some of the details but uh and
we did have a delay in some of the
vaccine coming in because the fiser
product wasn't approved for use until a
little bit later than expected so there
has been some um cases where vaccine and
where pharmacies in particular have run
out of vaccine but they continue to post
um and so I encourage anybody who
doesn't find an appointment right away
to uh to either call um our get
vaccinated number or to go back in and
look in in areas around where you are or
talk to your Pharmacy directly many of
the pharmacies particularly now that
we've got the vast majority of the
supply Supply in are offering walk-in
appointments as
[Music]
well uh in general the system has worked
extremely well witnessed the yesterday
the 30,000 plus people who uh Reed
vaccination appointments that in the
tens of thousands who made new
appointments so the system's working
well and we make adjustments as required
so there are some communities and right
now those communities change because
we've responded Victoria had less than
10% availability for a time and now it
has more um and so there are a number of
communities that have availability but
less than 10% availability of the number
of appointments provincewide about 50%
of appointments are available so there
are hundreds of thousands of available
appointments so generally speaking
you're going to be be able to find an
appointment on the site there are some
communities that we're looking at and I
was talking to roelly Russell who's our
MLA and all of our so and and gr Forks
about availability there and so we'll be
responding to that by increasing the
number of appointments in areas where
there's um right now less than 10% adult
availability and those include places uh
like uh right now Oliver so's uh
Peachland and um other areas like
Courtney uh and uh and Lake couch and so
we're making those adjustments as we go
along just a just a note and it's why
it's important to refresh as well
yesterday um uh yesterday uh about uh
20 6,000 more appointments were added to
the system so we're consistently adding
appointments to system so maybe that
today there's none at somewhere nearby
and you may have to go farther a field
which is not a problem in Metro
Vancouver but can be a problem elsewhere
so we're consistently adding
appointments to the system I I say well
over a thousand pharmacies involved and
health authority clinics as well
especially focused on children so
there's lots of availability and
opportunity and um and in general people
are booking in the tens of thousands
every single day so our system is
working well and I'm I'm really proud of
that system we we spent more on the
system um when we launched it and we've
been able to use that system as well for
the booking of uh of pharmacist
appointments for minor ement now it's
become a great base for people that
people are quite used to but uh if there
are issues uh it's important to keep
refreshing and keep trying so say you
booked an appointment for I don't know
November the 29th but you wanted one
soon keep checking the system because
you you may be able to BR to update that
uh that appointment and get one uh much
sooner did you have a followup Kate I do
yeah um just has to do with demand in
hospital I know it's high right now and
is probably expected to get higher as
the flu season continues um we're seeing
things like for example like a portable
outside the Siri hospital um to help
with some of the demand even just in
Waiting rooms and things like that
curious if you have any update on that
specific one outside of Siri Memorial or
if we're expected to see that sort of
thing at other hospitals to kind of help
with the demand yeah in in um June and I
reported on the first three months in
September and I'll be reporting on the
next three months uh in December we
started to take 30 measures uh at Ser
Memorial Hospital that were developed
with the staff at Sur Memorial Hospital
and this is one of the measures in other
words it's preparing for Respiratory
illness season and trying to make it
easier for people who are waiting um uh
in an emergency room in addition in Siri
we're adding spaces for people who don't
need to be in the hospital but have
challenges moving into the community
we're looking at Community spaces to
support them to improve patient flow if
someone doesn't need to be in the
hospital but needs some supports we want
to be able to provide them so that's
what we promis to do in Syria and that's
what we're delivering on and I think
everyone remembers this in their minds I
it feels like uh coid 19 sometimes it
lasted for a long time and I guess it
has it feels like it's lasted for longer
than the actual time but early on in the
pandemic and um Dr Henry and myself and
the whole team in this case of vanur
Coastal Health worked on it there was a
Mobile hospital set up at the convention
center about I don't know half a
kilometer from here where we're standing
and we never had to use it but we
prepared for it we didn't know what the
circumstances would have been there's
great uncertainty in this case we have a
sense of what respiratory illness season
would be like we worked with the staff
at Ser Memorial Hospital and we're
putting in uh Place measures to prepare
for the respiratory illness season and
to ensure that our healthcare workers
are supported but mostly our patients
are supported and that's what's
happening in
certain great we'll uh go to the phone
now first question to Katie D Roa from
the Vancouver Sun Katie go
ahead I can't hear you Katie can't hear
you okay we'll go to the next question
then Marella Bernardo
CBC everybody um my first question is
about something that Dr herry's already
touched on but hours after the BC CBC
reported that Co is waning we learned
there are outbreaks at hospitals in
Sanic chilak and Abid sword so could you
elaborate on what concerns you have
about that yeah so you know the fact
that it's um been going up and down in
terms of the community uh people who are
infected with coid gives us a sense of
what's happening it doesn't mean it's
not here and there are still people
getting sick and ending up in hospital
and hospitals are settings and uh
long-term care homes are settings where
we know that it can be transmitted quite
quite rapidly between people so we have
uh specific definitions for declaring
outbreaks um they are of different
severity in different places um and
thankfully with Co now because so many
people are vaccinated and because our
Healthcare System is uh well protected
through vaccination uh we're seeing
mostly mild illnesses in these outbreaks
but we have had a few um particularly
influenza outbreaks which have been more
severe and so
um it will depend on the situation and
the local mhos and infection control
practitioners work with the the units um
to determine you know is it an at risk
population what are the measures that we
need to put in place to try and control
these outbreaks but reporting of them is
incredibly important so that people
understand it's one of the things that
helps us uh understand the impact of
these viruses in our
communities great did you have a
followup
marchella I do it's for dicks if uh if
he could answer this it's mainly about
something that is happening here in
camls uh Minister I hate to ask you this
during this news conference but concerns
are again being raised here about the
timeline for completion of a new cancer
clinic in cam loops um please give us an
update on when that business plan for
this project will be delivered and can
you confirm construction will start as
promised in
2024 uh we're on track marchella uh you
say concerns have been raised I'm not
sure uh where they're being ra from uh
we uh have a 10-year cancer plan there
are new cancer centers in BC and coming
in camelops and N Nimo which are sort of
being developed concurrently uh and uh
Siri which is uh uh starting of course
starting construction now the second St
hospital and in bernabe and those are uh
we're on track uh remember we're going
to go from um 30,000 cancer diagnoses a
year to 45,000 in the next next 12 years
and that's a significant increase and
I've always believed that there should
be a Cancer Center in camelops um and
we're delivering on that so we're on
track uh and look forward to going
caroling with the open camet soon
Mar great the next question on the phone
is to Richard zisman Global News Richard
go
ahead man that caroling sounds fun uh Dr
Henry you use some broader language
about uh when people are think they
should stay home in the past has just
been that six stay home they made more
specific reference to fever and other
types of symptoms why the change are you
worried that people are achieving this
advice as people get back to normaly
Christmas events and all those sort of
things yeah it's it's more um there's a
lot of mild illness in a lot of people
we have a lot more immunity to some of
the uh well to coid uh for example right
now so it is the things that we know are
most associated with infections that can
transmit to others are fever and you
know that's a marker that you have
something that you need to pay attention
to that you need to stay away from
others so fever and a cough is is one of
the Hallmarks of uh of respiratory
illnesses whether it's from influenza
from RSV from um uh or from SARS coov V2
so just being a little bit more specific
if you have mild allergies for example
you may not need to stay home it's more
uh giving people some uh specific advice
on on the the the things that are most
important Great Richard did you have a
follow-up I can go I can go we know that
vaccination uptake at the beginning is
often higher these are the people who
really want to get vaccin and then it
starts to Lan how worried are you that
we may be hitting that Wayan earlier
considering how huge the update has been
early on I know Minister dicks mentioned
how many appointments were yesterday but
are we starting to get worried about out
the harder to get people actually going
to get their vaccine and what are we
doing to change our approach in order to
reach some of those people yeah that's
one of the reasons we're we're talking
to people today to remind people I think
the fact that we have our reminder
system is really important it does make
it personal when that to remind us that
these are things we can do and it's not
too late that's the other thing that
sometimes um people think so we are at
the peak of where we expect to see
vaccinations um be very high as you say
we started off with people who are most
at risk and we know um that we're
getting really good uptake in that group
but there's lots of room yet we're not
seeing a slowing down yet um and we
expect things to be uh quite uh risk all
through November and that's that's good
this is the time to get the protection
as we're starting to see the viruses get
get more and more active in the
community so you'll have the best
protection as we go into particularly
the holidays when we're getting together
so there's no slowing down that we see
on the horizon Now's the Time to do it
to get uh the protection for yourself
and for those around
you great next question goes to Claudia
vaner Global News Claudia go
ahead hi thank you so much for taking my
question uh this uh is for minst Dex um
can you uh talk to us a little bit about
uh the situation with opgyn in the
Interior Health Region uh buron is
expecting shortages later this month I
understand Royal Inland in C we have
three consecutive days without an obgy
in next week how aware are you of this
critical situation what's being done
about
it well it's to say the least a huge
focus of our effort um and our effort
with um with doctors and communities
we've uh been meeting these challenges
but they're real in places such as
Vernon I personally was there meeting uh
with doctors on this and other questions
uh in the summer and that's why we have
I think the most um exceptional uh
Health Human Resources plan in the
country and we've seen very dramatic
increases this year ac across um
different types of care there are
different challenges and this is one of
the areas that we've really been focused
on across um across the spectrum of care
um and uh we're continuing to work on it
so we're very aware of it very focused
on providing supports for people we know
the concerns that the uncertainty
involve uh can can create over um this
year for example we've recruited uh
internationally medical graduates well
over um 500 in fact over 550 now which
we're going to set an all-time record uh
by a mile almost double the previous
record in terms of that Recruitment and
we're working in areas where the new um
payment model um has left some gaps and
those include um for example long-term
care and we're been working very closely
with the doctors of BC on that doctors
who work and support uh residents in
long-term care uh in maternity care uh
which is very important and obviously
we've been doing work over the last
number of months with hospitals and we
have an in we've had an interim
agreement with there and we're looking
for a permanent one so you're seeing
this across the spectrum of care and uh
we have unprecedented response by doctor
to the payment model that we
co-developed with the doctors at BC uh
but there are some areas of care where
there are still gaps and that's why uh
we are uh recruiting relentlessly and
trying to support communities where
they're issues whether it's in the
emergency room or particular type of
care but this is a obviously a
significant focus of us and and we want
we want to ensure uh we want to have uh
as little uncertainty as possible for
people and what is going to be a very
Challen challenging time in every
hospital on
VC Claudia did you have a
followup I do yes and on the same topic
I know that part of the plan you know is
sending um women to perhaps other
hospitals sometimes an hour or more um
away um and of course that has its own
set of risks so um what happens if you
know a hospital is another hospital uh
that we sending pregnant with to is
overwhelmed and can't accept transfers
I'd like to know what safety measures
are being put in place right now to
ensure that babies and expectant moms
lives are not at risk well um we have a
comprehensive uh Health Care system so
um uh and so uh preparation is made if
there's an interruption of service
somewhere to prepare to support that
service somewhere else and that's what
you've seen at times during this period
of very high uh demand in the Health
Care System I'll just give you an
example um because I was meeting with uh
Dr in Colona in Vernon uh in the
Okanagan through the summer and we have
seen a very significant in terms of uh
uh babies increase in demand we went
through four or five years leading into
2022 when there was um really flat
overall demand in Maternity in the
region of placees like Colona and then
we went two years of increase of 7% 14%
which were unexpected some of that was
due uh to um new resident of those
communities but there was an increase in
demand and we're working to uh respond
to that so yes every time there's a
service Interruption first of all we're
doing everything we can to avoid that
and second of all there's a plan in
place to support um to support people
when they have to uh if they were have
to to go to a neighboring Hospital say
from Vernon to Colona for
example next question goes to Graham
wood with Glacier news Graham go
ahead well hi this is High acing
ar oh well it's it's Bonnie back at the
table but that's
okay I was to speak to Okay go
ahead hi uh yeah so I was speaking to a
doctor and they are expressing a bit of
concern about how Urban Family Doctor
clinics are being I guess under a bit
more pressure even despite the the
payment model so I think they rais a few
things here like the business cost
premium tip Urban care clinics that are
trally owned doctors are not being paid
for their panel payments or
reimbursed um the current payment model
does not factor in group care for
patients seeing
locom and just generally the
cost uh pressures on these CL that are
continuing to um pile up on so Min what
what are you doing to further
incentivize CL operat especially in
urban urban settings so um um let's be
clear uh the new payment system is
unbelievably popular with doctors uh and
has been uh I think very effective in
stabilizing the system and increasing
the system so more and more and more
doctors are uh are involved in primary
care than even a year ago uh I think the
the net number is between 6 and 700 I
can give you the exact number uh uh gram
later we can provide you the exact
number there are some some challenges I
think in Primary Care um particularly
for some walking clinics so we've taken
action and made very specific offers for
stabilization plans for walking clinics
in different parts of the province made
a series of offers in addition of course
we have invested in a lot of areas I
know you're often interested in Richmond
gram uh we have a Primary Care Network
there with uh a very very large U number
of team-based care supports we have an
urgent Primary Care Center there and um
and we have a contract with doctors that
has taken us to at or near and most
categories to the top of the country in
terms of support for doctors so uh given
that this is um uh a remarkable and
revolutionary change in the way that we
address primary care I think is going
very well and it's going very well
because we're working with thect doctors
of BC every day on every element of this
there were some issues I I in response
to the previous question we talked about
maternity care we talked about um uh
care for residents and long-term care
and we're we're taking uh all of the
remaining issues and working with them
issue by issue uh with Walkin clinics as
well and uh we're continuing to doing
that work together but I I don't think
you can draw any other conclusion with
the increase in the numbers of doctors
increase in the numbers of young doctors
involved in Family Practice the success
of the model the increase in the number
of people who want to be involved in
Family Medicine the new attachments
through our health match BC system is
going well there are always issues and
we work our way through them as with all
major change but this one has been going
very
well did you have a
followup great yeah um thank you for
that um at a higher level of thought I
guess um doctors are you know they're
coming out of med school with $250,000
of debt and there's a lot of pressure on
them now even in these Urban clinics um
and I know that there's a loan for gness
program for if you're in an underserved
Community uh 20% per year up to right I
guess the whole portion of the BT
student home would be forgiven um I
guess the question is have you thought
about expanding that program uh
especially including
bigger incentives for Rural doctors but
also including Urban people who are
working in urban clinics as well well in
in June of 2022 we launched a new to
practice doctor program which was
transformative uh for family practice
that included um things such as uh loan
forgiveness and increase in un to
practice doctors to encourage them uh to
uh to um join and support Family
Practice it has been uh uh breathtaking
in its success and uh the issues such as
loan forgiveness are part of it so the
new to practice contracts for both
doctors and indeed nurse practitioners
have all addressed those issues and we
see that and if you recall as well in
addition with resident doctors the
highest ratification as you'll recall
the contract with doctors was negotiated
was ratified at 96% with ambulance
paramedics at 96% but the one for
resident doctors was I think ratified at
99% indicating our priority on new to
practice doctors and it's those very
doctors young doctors uh new doctors who
have been most supportive of the new
payment model of course because they um
have a different view than has
historically been the case in terms of
wanting to run a business and so these
new to practice models the new um lfp
model have been focused on that area and
I'm happy to provide you details of new
to practice contracts grant for your
story great thank you next question goes
to Chuck Chang from the Canadian press
go ahead Chuck
hi thank you um question is for Dr Henry
uh first thing just uh I was wondering
if Dr Henry can uh walk us through you
mentioned earlier that the worst of the
season is uh maybe uh traditionally is
coming up in a couple weeks um uh if he
is there any possibility of providing us
with some historical context of usually
when the Pete seasons are and how does
the current lower numbers play into
that sure so if we think about prior to
the pandemic the main viruses that
caused uh most severe illness that we
were seeing during the winter season uh
were influenza both influenza A and B
and also RSV so RSV has always been out
there um it's certainly been um more
challenging in the last two years
because we had a period of time uh when
uh the co pandemic was at its peak where
we didn't see influenza um for almost 2
years and we saw very little RSV and
that's really a reflection of how
influenza in particular and how all of
these viruses spread around the world
and they spread through travel and
through contact with people so during
the peak of the pandemic globally when
people weren't traveling around the
world we saw a dramatic decrease so
normally the seasons that we would see
prior to the pandemic uh we would start
to see influenza in in October November
and usually our Peak was sometime um
after the holiday season when people
were traveling a lot more and coming
together um so in mid to late January
sometimes as late as February and we
often would see a second peak of
influenza be um later in the season so
into February March and sometimes even
as late as April so those are historic
trends that we see those have been
disrupted in the last few years mostly
because of the the lack of travel and
and what we saw last year was quite
different where influenza came back um
and it came early and we saw that uh in
the southern hemisphere as well where we
had an early Peak it was up dramatically
in October November and the peak was in
November and then it went down and we
had very little influenza for the rest
of the season so that's um something
that we were watching we're not seeing
that pattern this year thankfully we're
seeing a something that's more going
back to the usual patterns for influenza
we have started to see um
outbreaks as we mentioned in long-term
care and we're starting to see increases
in detections in our Wastewater
surveillance so that tells us that
influenza is circulating and that we're
likely to see more of it um if we go
back to the previous uh prepandemic U
patterns we're likely to see a peak in
January and we may see some influenza be
later in the season last year as well we
saw an early Peak at the same time as we
were seeing this influenza um peak of
RSV particularly in young people and
we're starting to see that increase in
younger people and children um
especially young children so that's
something we need to be prepared for and
that's some of the uh um measures that
we saw being taken at Children's
Hospital at Sur Memorial places where uh
have Pediatric Care um so we're starting
to see that increase a little bit as
well we know that immunization makes a
big difference in helping to settle
those things down down and what we are
seeing now um is that we have a new
virus in the mix and that's the SARS K2
virus and whether it's going to follow
patterns that uh have this earlier Peak
and maybe a later peak in the spring we
don't know that yet so uh the monitoring
is still telling us that reminds us that
there is still a lot to learn although
for the most part what we're seeing is
smaller and smaller oscillations of of
the SARS kov V2 and not as dramatically
different changes in the virus as we are
seeing in the first few years and partly
that's because of the level of immunity
we have across the board as I mentioned
from combinations of vaccination and
infections that make it less easy for
the virus to to gain a hold and and to
take off even if it has um a slight
advantage in terms of infectivity so
those are all um neat stuff that we're
following in the science of this virus
and the evolution of the viruses over
time um and that's why it's so important
that we keep track of these things and
um we post that information and there's
no one single thing that tells us what's
happening it's a matter of looking at
different um whether it's
hospitalizations um visits to Primary
Care the Wastewater surveillance all of
things things together give us a sense
of what's happening and so I believe we
are going to see more influenza in the
next few weeks um we're likely to see a
peak in uh December January very similar
to what we saw prior to uh the pandemic
and uh still um unknown what we're going
to see with with SARS CO2 over the next
few months Chuck did you have a
followup yes thank you uh Dr Henry the
with the recent lower uh Co 19 activity
and uh the the CDC numbers that came out
yesterday in the k um do you have any
concerns that people might believe that
the the Cur third wave the spike that we
saw in the late summer early fall of Co
is over you know are you you know are
there any concerns regarding how to make
sure people's guards are up despite the
the fact that the activity numbers are
lower and you know um is is is it
correct for people to assume that this
this latest spike is over thank you yeah
well I think the the the key word you
said there is lower so yes we saw a peak
um a couple of weeks ago and things are
seem to be settling down but that also
corresponds with um immunization
particularly people who are most at risk
so we started with uh older people um
people who had immune system dysfunction
for example or immune systems weren't a
strong so um I it does tell us again how
important vaccination is at trying to
stop the spread of this virus and it
protects us as an individual but it also
means that there's less of it around to
spread to others so I think that's what
part of what we're seeing right now and
uh we're just going to need to watch and
that's why we're saying today how
important it is it's not too late this
is not over it's not behind us um and it
has still um come back and surprised Us
in the past there are many things and I
think it's sort of humility in the face
of this changing virus um we still don't
know everything about it yet we know a
lot more about influenza than we do
about about SARS coov V2 but we're
learning and this will be another season
that will help us understand for next
year what we might expect but right now
it's important that we do take that
measure of protecting ourselves and
those around us and uh getting
vaccinated is the way to do
that great the next question goes to
Lauren Collins with black press Lauren
go
ahead hi my question is for Dr Henry
it's around the Aven influenza so are
these outbreak the 16 that have been
reported worse than in previous Seasons
yeah so we don't have I mean previous
seasons is a bit of an anomaly generally
with Aven influenza what we've seen is
is outbreaks that we have been able to
contain and get rid of and you may
remember in uh 2004 there was a big one
that uh and and when we talk about high
pathogenic Aven influenza what we're
talking about is the impact of the virus
on poultry so chickens turkeys in
particular and Ducks so um these these
have been devastating to the Farms that
are affected and the uh response to them
so that it doesn't spread more is is
unfortunately having to call the birds
and so we did see last year that there
was that this h5n1 that has been
spreading globally as I mentioned across
the US and Canada caused Devastation for
large number of farms the last outbreak
that we had was on April 29th of this
year and so we were all holding our
breath and waiting to see what was going
to happen in this migratory season in
the fall so um globally uh wild fowl
migrate at two different times of the
year and that's when they can bring the
viruses with them and shed them into uh
new areas so I know the poultry industry
has been working very hard on what we
call biocurity making sure that uh the
the birds that they grow are protected
from um exposure to Wild Birds whether
it's through feed through water through
um people coming in and out of of the
Farms um but this year we're also seeing
again uh that Farms can be easily
affected some of them are large
commercial Farms um some of them are
smaller backyard flocks um so in terms
of severity of the illness for the birds
it's been devastating and those farms
and farm families who have been affected
it's been very very challenging for them
um and thankfully this is not a virus
that spreads very easily from birds to
humans but we still need to be very
careful about that and what I was
talking about is this time of year when
we have human influenza viruses
spreading between people and if we have
somebody who gets infected with both a
human and a bird virus that virus can
reassort we call it and create a new
influenza virus that could um be more
infectious to humans and so that's a
risk that's in the back of our mind all
the time with these um but working very
carefully with the cfia to try and um
stop these uh the viruses from spreading
between poultry farms and that's the big
Focus right
now we it is becoming clear that this
h5n1 that is spreading in in um wild
water fowl is likely to become endemic
in those um populations so in wild birds
and that's going to mean it's a risk for
the future as well um we still don't
know all the details about that but the
fact that it's come back again with this
migratory season is very
worrisome Lauren did you have a
followup no that is it for me thank you
thank you great thank you the next
question goes to Cindy Harnett with the
Times Colonist Cindy go
ahead oh thanks so much uh Dr Henry I
hope you'll forgive me for going off
topic and uh way back in time but um can
you tell me where you are with your um
report on the recommendations to improve
safe Supply and um and in your response
to the province's rejection of
recommendation of providing
nonprescription safer Supply and what if
any influence did that rejection have on
on the finalization of your report yeah
so as um as I've been um quite open
about um I was asked to to have a look
at um The Limited uh prescribed model
that we have for alternatives to the
toxic drug Supply um mostly because of
concerns being expressed about how it
was working uh concerns that providers
have about uh whether the medications
that were available were the right ones
and so I spent quite a lot of time over
the last few months uh listening to a
lot of groups of people um one of the
things that I know has been out uh at
least talked about publicly was part of
that which is a what we heard report
which is again uh a draft right now and
I am working on a a broader Report with
some recommendations to government about
what I've heard we're in the final
phases of that and I expect to uh have
it to government within the next uh few
weeks and uh our expectation is that uh
we will make all of this public when
they're in the finalized form later this
year so to be clear there is this what
we heard report there's a report with my
recommendations to government coming out
of uh the consultations we've done
there's uh also um a literature review
that has been done by the BC Center on
substance use um that they've provided
to me to help guide some of the work I'm
doing and we also have a an ethical
review from a population Health
perspective that our provincial ethics
team led by Dr Dr Alice fani has been
working on as well so those are four
important pieces that we're in the final
stages and uh will be coming out and uh
will be shared publicly later this
year Cindy did you have a
followup yes D thank you so much for
that I mean Dr Henry um Minister dicks
three clinics have been told by the
medical um Services Commission to shut
down their private pay MRI operations
can you comment on the of um this
problem in BC and how stopping them um
impacts you know positively or
negatively weight times for
diagnos well um as as you know Cindy
we've set um uh and then shattered every
record for Diagnostic testing and BC um
both uh for MRIs and CT scans in the
last number of years which is an
extraordinary success given the pandemic
there is significant demand as well with
respect to these cases is we uh make in
British Columbia uh we set the uh we we
write the law and we make the law and
the regulations and the medical service
commission enforces the law and in this
case the medical service commission is
doing exactly what it should do which is
enforce the law and uh we've seen this
in other cases recently and um and what
it shows is our robust determination not
only to deliver diagnostic care in
unprecedented numbers and to break every
record we have so that more people can
get care keeping our public MRIs open uh
uh as you know 24 hours a day people
often tell me about their appointments
at 3: in the morning and and also um
working to ensure everyone's acting
within the law and uh that's our
expectation that's what we're going to
continue to do and our and the people
who do that who enforce the law and
ensure that happened to the Medical
Services Commission of course they have
my support but they're also independent
of me and they're doing EX exactly what
they should be doing which is ensuring
that the law is enforced so that
patients are given protection and
support we have time for one last
question and it goes to Yan lost France
for CBC Radio Canada Yan go
ahead perfect thank you very
much
[Music]
we just say in English that you know we
talk about Peaks and valleys of Co 19 we
know what's going to peak in the next
few weeks and that's coming together uh
in our communities and so this is the
time to get protected means of course in
healthcare uh uh it's it means wearing
masks in hospitals it means wearing
masks in Care Homes and uh it but it
mostly means that this is the ideal time
today to book your
vaccination
in not
system um the the
[Music]
Sy
ad
[Music]
Mery thank you very much and that
concludes today's
event